so some fatty with a social media
following uh tried to go horseback
riding and she was over 240 pounds which
is bad as like it's it's sorry guys
bad as hell bad as heck like fat 240.
I'm six foot I'm not over 200 like uh
like the average woman's like five five
six
and you're 240 pounds
okay but let's play the clip so this
tick tocker wanted to go horseback
riding and she contacts a horse ranch
and schedules a ride and she gets there
and apparently they wouldn't let her
ride because there's a weight limit and
she happens to weigh more than the 240
pound limit and according to her they
were rude to her about it while turning
her away they told me that I could not
go on the horse because I was too big
but they didn't tell me that in the
beginning so in response she posts this
Tick Tock about it shout out to deep
Hollow Ranch for making me lead because
I weigh over 240. but she's got a big
audience so the video blows up pretty
quickly and gets several million views
and her audience sees the video and they
get mad and they start review bombing
the ranch on Yelp this horse ranch is
terrible I would never ride horses here
are all horses hung like a horse and in
response to the review bombing an
employee of the ranch who also happens
to be the owner's son he makes a tick
tock when you're not a fact you can ride
a deep Olive Ranch and wow that is that
is definitely a response so of course
that response blows off and that's when
traditional news sources start picking
up the store
[Laughter]
thank you you know that's what we need
I'm tired of the simping Dave Dave you
gotta you gotta speak out about this
this is ridiculous these chicks honestly
I've seen Barstool I used to love bar
stool sports but since they brought in
so many women it's just the same I
bet they get a lawsuit I bet you they
get a lawsuit in the next three years
for some sexual harassment blah blah
blah like I hear the Bree chick
complaining then I hear
um this chick complaining like I'm just
so done with all of the whining
lose weight 240 pounds as fat as
like that that is so fat like get on the
track I don't care what you got to do I
don't care if you starve yourself I
don't care if you get on the treadmill
but 240 is ridiculous you're gonna give
yourself a freaking heart attack so
instead of whining bitching to everyone
else about oh boo hoo boohoo I can't
ride a horse yeah because the horse is
gonna suffocate under your blubber
that's what's gonna happen is you're
you're literally gonna you're gonna kill
the horse because you're so fat lose
some weight and come back that's not the
ranch's fault that you're too fat to get
on the horse stop whining and crying and
any guy that co-signs this is an
absolute simp because he's not telling
you the truth and the truth is you got
to lose weight chica